Понад 12 мільярдів євро
саме стільки фінансової допомоги отримала Україна
від ЄС за останні три роки.
Велика сума і - велика спокуса для корупціонерів.
ЄC запевняє: гроші європейських платників податків
надійно захищені від розкрадань.
Контрольний механізм функціонує на кількох рівнях.
Перший рівень - тендери.
Нині в Україні Євросоюз реалізує п'ятсот ретельно відібраних проектів.
Кожен з них моніторить окремий європейський менеджер.
Це другий рівень.
У разі підозр менеджер підключає третій рівень
замовляє зовнішній аудит.
І якщо зловживання підтверджуються, то залучають Генпрокуратуру України
та OLAF - Європейське відомство з протидії шахрайству.
Через такий суворий контроль українські чиновники
виявляють небажання займатися західними грантами.
Мовляв, якщо шансів нагріти руки немає
інтерес до грошей ЄС втрачається.
Утім, у деяких випадках винахідливі українці і тут знаходять лазівки:
підрядники - часто у змові з відповідальними за це чиновниками
виграють тендери і - зникають з грошима.
І коли ЄС вимагає повернути кошти,
Україна змушена робити це за рахунок держбюджету.
Окрім проектних грошей, є ще макрофінансова допомога ЄС.
Її надають після підписання угод і меморандумів
в обмін на обіцянки Києва провести реформи.
Однак реалізація цих реформ блокується тими,
чиї корупційні схеми або й просто бізнес-інтереси опиняються під загрозою.
Тож, навчені досвідом європейці дають гроші
тільки після успішної реалізації попереднього етапу реформ.
Так, у листопаді Єврокомісія не виплатила Україні третій транш
макрофінансової допомоги у розмірі шестисот мільйонів євро.
Бо з 24-х вимог Брюсселя чотири залишилися невиконаними.
Але пропонувати гроші в обмін на продовження реформ ЄС не припиняє
наразі Києву обіцяють пряник у розмірі майже двох мільярдів євро.